هل تسقط باخموت في قبضه قوه الروسيه في ظل
احتدام المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني
الاخبار الوارده من هناك تفيد ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لازالت صامده لكنها تواجه
صعوبه امام الهجمات الروسيه الشرسه بقياده
قوه فاجنر ان الواضح ان جبهه القتال في
الشرق الاوكراني باتت الاكثر اشتعالا في
ظل رغبه روسيه واضحه في السيطره على باخم
والبلدات المجاوره لها ابرز هذه البلدات
المجاوره
» والتي تشهد حرب شوارع بين القوه الروسيه
ونظراتها الاوكرانيه لكن الوضع الحالي
لمدينه يبقى غامضه الفضل لتضارب الانباء
حيث تؤكد موسكو ان قواتها تتقدم في عمق
المدينه هذا في الوقت الذي يقول فيه الجيش
الاوكراني ان صلد دار لا تزال تحت سيطرته
واذا كانت موسكو قد اكتفت بالاشاره الى
تقدمها في سندار فانها اكدت سيطرتها على
بلده ضخمه ديسك التي لا تبعد سوى تسعه
كيلومترات عن مدينه
ومع استمرار المعارك شمال دنيتك يواصل
الجيش الروسي قصف الامدادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه المتجهه من مدينه باخمط الى
بلده سوليدار وفي حصيله اوليه قتل العشرات
من الجنود الاوكرانيين خلال القصف المستمر
على الطريق السريع بين باخبط وسوليدار
فيما قصف الجيش الروسي الطريقه السريع
بالمدفعيه ورجمات الصواريخ
التطورات تتسارعوا اذا في الشرق الاوكراني
في ظل الزحف الروسي المتواصل هناك وهو ما
دفع القوات الاوكرانيه الى تعزيز صفوفها
في منطقه الشرقيه بشكل عام سعيا منها
للتصدي للهجمات الروسيه المستمره والى
جانب هذه التعزيزات توجهها قائد القوات
البريه
العقيد اوليكساندر سيريسكي شخصيا الى ضخمه
وذلك لرفع معنويات الجيش ومتابعه اخر
التطورات
في المقابل وجهه القوات الروسيه ضربه
استهدفت فيها انظمه انظمه المدفعيه
الامريكيه تصنع وردرات مضاده للبطاريات في
دمشق بحسب وزاره الدفاع ومن يذكر مبروك
مساء الخير صهيب بالفعل هي يعني هو المحور
الاكثر سخونه في المعارك هنا في الشرق
الاوكراني حيث ان قوات باكنر والقوات
الشيشانيه اضافه الى القوات المواليه
لروسيا من لوكانس تتقدم من المحور الشمالي
من اجل الوصول الى باتمان لكنها تتعرقل
ااه بلده سلداره التي بعدت تقدم فيها
الاراضي بلده والاخرى
كما ان بلده
هي الاخيره ما زالت القوات الروسيه تتقدم
همم واسطه مواجهه او يعني صمود نوعا مال
الجيش الاوكراني لكن العنف في القصف
الروسي والمدفعيه كما ان سلاح الجو
الطيران الروسي ايضا يعمل من اجل التقدم
في هذا المحور والسيطر على بلده سندار
التي اا يعني تعتبر الطوق ال همم المكتمل
من الناحيه الشماليه
اذا تم السيطره عليها حيث ان القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على
المدينه همم
ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه كما ذكرت القوه
الاوكرانيه تحاول جاهده الصمود
الى متى سيستمر هذا الصمود خاصه في ظل
القصف الروسي همم كما تفضلت ولماذا يعني
كل هذه الاستماته للسيطره على باخره
بدايه يعني قطع الاتصال عن القوات
الاوكرانيه او المقاتلين على الجبهات من
القوات الاوكرانيه عن القواعد القياديه في
المركز في باخمط او حتى في المدن الاكبر
عبر استهداف القواعد
الاتصالاتيه المرتبطه
بالقمر الصناعي ستارلينج
ترك كثيرا على صمود هذه القوات الاوكرانيه
لان ليس لديها جهات اتصال مع القاعده
القياديه وذلك ما يجعل الجيش الروسي يتقدم
في هذا المحور وقت يعني قطع الامدادات
ايضا عن الجيش الاوكراني كما اسلفت صهيب
حيث ان الطريق السريع ما بين فخمه تستهدفه
والصواريخ والقذائف الروسيه باستمرار هناك
حديث عن قتل اكثر من 100 جندي بهذا المحور
يعني المدينه تعتبر استراتيجيه مدينه
لانها هي المفتاح الرئيس للدخول الى المدن
الكبرى
المياه نهر الذي يعني يمنع المياه عن كل
المقاطعه لن يستلذلك تعتبر همم من اهم
المدن وهي الاكثر استراتيجيه حتى الان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا الحديث مباشره